before we start I want to thank him for
sponsoring this video they are a new
men's wellness brand that helps out with
issues like hair loss edie and at me
yeah so make sure to check out the link
in the description to get your own
comprehensive haircut for just 5 all of
this for 5 dollars baby Oh in single on
shuttle news that's awesome
submit it by not impressed me neither a
new taxi service is offering free rides
and it's startup but you have to sing
the whole time oh [ __ ] the way you pay
is with your voice oh my god that must
be [ __ ] horrible for the driver so
what's the point are they recording all
the people singing is it a voice powered
vehicle they're trying to say like it's
the boys power because as soon as you
stop singing the taxi stops all for a
human driver so take them on the freeway
so you can't even breathe so I'll show
you guys a video clip promoting this
service so by the way this is for
Finland Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's dope I don't understand what the
hell they're saying though a long
shuttle when I hear music from other
countries I feel like it's an alternate
universe you mean like it's like almost
like America but not really [ __ ]
beeps are the same all that [ __ ] you
know it's like pop music
that's how globally connected we are
it's just a the same [ __ ] different
language that's all it is yeah it makes
me go oh yeah you guys exist two laws
forget the only music I know is American
music and then I hear some Asian [ __ ]
here and there and I hear some Spanish
it here and there but then when I hear
my German rap I'm like oh yeah you guys
do too you didn't like that concept of
people loving what's it called kpop so
much is so odd to me dude and like the
the fandom that they have for it is
[ __ ] insane man like we don't even
have Americans who have American fandom
like that for American artists you know
yes true age of like American people
that have crazy fandom force you know it
was crazy
we went to Puerto Rico that was the
deepest [ __ ] like you're trying to
steal all the air greedy so this is my
moment
that was a good Center go back to it set
it up again set it up some to Puerto
Rico and we landed in the airport there
was this huge crowd of fangirls and we
just keep hearing all these screwy like
I can do it yeah you're doing a lot of
people material and you did
anyway so then I find out it was all for
a k-pop group that was there and they
were in for Rudy gone yeah what are they
called
I know em I couldn't understand the girl
that was telling me cuz it was still a
lot of screaming it's up its
international girl but it's in the blog
it's so interesting like I kind of want
to understand why the fandom gets so
crazy yeah I mean is it a relatability
babies travel their lives and everything
so it's not just the music like it's
like WWE [ __ ] right like baby but even
you don't really get to follow their
lives because they're really secretive
yeah you don't know their lives no I
thought that there's the no not k-pop
stars there but lights are dorrigo on
shows and [ __ ] - they do variety shows
but you don't know anything about them
them yeah
I recently randomly watched the
documentary on this [ __ ] it's all
science like everything's broken down to
a science
a lot of their songs has like every
[ __ ] genre in it at some point so
there's something for everybody to like
like so you just love the music like
make these scientifically made you
follow up with the music yeah pretty
much
that's crazy have you looked into it
okay part yeah um not really
I've heard some [ __ ] that I like I went
to a concert once yeah we randomly got
invited to like kpop fest at the
convention center yeah it's cool bunch
of people there but then it was a
concert after at Staples - it was packed
yeah baby was [ __ ] sold a house over
oh alright
it can pack out [ __ ] like nothing do it
and if their fandom is so [ __ ] crazy
there's also respect for the people who
started the art you know what I mean
like the oh jeez like you don't see like
Boyz II Men packing out staples anymore
oh yeah but these og k-pop stars they'll
pack that [ __ ] out and then some still
because they still respect that art is
kind of like how people who pick up rock
they still respect the og rock artists
like rap is a little different for some
reason for some reason like the young
rappers they like to disrespect older
people at least the new ones do yeah the
view ones do which is a little odd like
cuz I don't see that like it rock like
rock they're like oh like I used to
listen to [ __ ] Leonard Skynyrd or
whatever all's of the [ __ ] you know they
don't have that same respect and hip-hop
because hip-hop changes drastically it's
different with each generation so then
it's like y'all doing it wrong the older
people say that it's like we're doing
that we do rock is pretty much the same
[ __ ] mmm forever
you know saying is just fine-tuned but
it's the same sample over okay pop
actually started from a group called
Chad our baggies nothing man is that
thing called jet skis or something like
that but when they first came out and
they started performing what they were
doing everybody that was like listening
to their music was telling them that
they were doing it all wrong but this is
not what music is but then they blew up
out of God knows how you know I mean I
don't know the exact history but I
forgot what the name is but I know the
the artist by see their face but they
were the first people who started this
group of like kpop which is a boy band
and they had like rap elements in it
yeah you know and it wasn't really
singing it was like rap mixed with this
it's just weird thing that people
couldn't really grasp on to but then it
kind of blew up it's been around since I
was a kid like I remember in elementary
school everyone was going crazy over
this group called h.o.t oh yeah there it
was supposedly high high five of
teenager or something like that but they
were huge remember my friend introduced
me to DJ doc and I was like yeah how is
that a DJ when there's a group oh yeah
and I was just trying to get words that
would be relatable yeah everywhere
because in the documentary I think
whatever you're talking about is who I
saw and they basically got their [ __ ]
from New Kids on the Block oh yeah yeah
how's that feel to it that was I thought
that was funny it's like uh well you
know amber she's she's a part of FX yeah
yeah so I don't know [ __ ] about kpop but
then when we're taking pictures with or
whatever her fans are so strong that
like in the comments it's nothing but oh
my god it's amber oh my god it's amber
oh my god and I'm like damn girl
I didn't know how hardcore like your
fans were that's it's really hard like I
mean like even that kid jay Park
oh dude to rock Rockefeller right so he
was a part of that original group
whatever 6 p.m. 4 p.m. work I think it's
I think it's 2 p.m. ok ITP and so cheap
it was one of those groups
and he whenever he did his own thing and
he broke off his fans followed him here
mmm
you know and then he still had his own
like fervor just from his own [ __ ] right
and then I had I put him in a sketch
that's all it was to Jay Part A Part A
Part A Part that's about it I think give
a [ __ ] about sketches we did a show in
him a long time ago and this is like the
first show where people had dressing
rooms all of us had a dressing room and
then he had dressing room how lonely and
it was lined with gifts from fans she
never seen that [ __ ] before and we're
like we never heard of him I want to be
10 years younger and try to be a kpop
star that's what I need to do me because
that type of love that they have for
them is weird he's got to get my face
back kpop people are attractive I know
but they get surgeries about sign like
God type of miracle surgery yeah
straight up
how about sigh please come in you made
it he's the biggest one sighs an
interesting phenomenon he's a musician I
find a little different though he's like
one of those og people and then on top
of that he or he came from money yeah I
don't think people really classify them
as kpop pop in the traditional sense
it's like um make your funny uncle no I
mean no so I was actually be one of the
biggest stars out there originally like
originally he was before his reinvention
yeah he's actually done this same type
of music since day one so he was like
huge I'm talking about like pet our
parents know who he is
oh I mean that's how big he is and then
you know he probably did that algorithm
[ __ ] you know what everybody likes and
they just bump with people and you know
but when you come from money you can
make anything happen
is this the article have anything to a
kpop music it's do the same topic yeah
well why are they doing that is it for
promotion yeah it's pretty much a
promotion turbo I think that's what the
group will stomp sorry it's a promotion
by for Tom which is a clean energy
company based in Northern Europe they
are unveiling this sing-along shuttle
during the weekend of this music
festival in Finland and so yeah they're
just pretty much promoting the the
vehicle like hell how quiet it is and
you have
be louder than the car like the only
noise you should be hearing in that car
is your voice oh that's such a bad idea
so they have this tablet where they have
you can pick out which song you want and
then has the lyrics and you have to sing
along and if you stop singing then the
shuttle stops because it's a line I
don't want you to hear how loud the
[ __ ] car is so they stuff it I'll
rather have a car that's powered by
silence you talking to the [ __ ] dude
I can't it can't go anywhere
well you [ __ ] said something man [ __ ]
yeah perfect we have toddlers in the car
I think we're not going anywhere not
going to Disneyland
we're gonna get there forever it's kind
of weird though cause like the Tesla -
like if I turn off the air conditioning
and I don't have any music on it's a
little weird like this it's look quiet
mmm it's look too quiet like I need
something so I hope we just turn on the
the climate like you know the AC cuz
it's just [ __ ] silent [ __ ] is it you
know sometimes I don't even like music
anymore I just listen
I barely listen to music anymore when I
Drive now what do you listen to part s
podcasts are almost into [ __ ] yeah the
asphalt and the tires because usually
what happens on just blank out and I'll
just drive and whatever I'm in my
thoughts is [ __ ] but then like I used to
love bumping music super loud unless
like a dope ass album comes out or like
some [ __ ] that I've been waiting for or
just I'm just filling in that mood then
I'll put it on but the now is just a
silent suppose it yeah I don't really
bump your car to be I like it that's it
and after that I turn it down okay drink
your elbow use your whole [ __ ] albums
top 10 right now I know man like [ __ ]
like okay fine I'm just gonna listen to
trees and [ __ ]
[Music]